Lu Laden ones and her team in the
Guardians digital newsroom check the top
social media topics every morning on
Twitter an advisor to the Nigerian
president alleges that an opposition
party is offering food and money in
exchange for votes the news spreads
quickly so the Guardian team decides to
investigate such the image found out it
was a lie I mean the photograph detailed
as far back as 2017 it was a photograph
from an outreach done by a charity
foundation in Vegas so it wasn't what
she said it was shortly after the
Guardian publishes its findings the
politicians tweets are deleted the team
here say they see fake stories like this
every day so if it's text it's a lot
easier in the sense that you just need
to you know call up a few people whoever
who's who's making this claim who's seen
this happen you know call up the person
if it's a photograph it's also somewhat
easy I mean the technology is quite
simple to handle you can research with
Chennai there's a whole lot of them but
when it's videos it becomes a little bit
more complicated because once video gets
on social medias trending on Twitter
you have the metadata stripped off and
sometimes that's what you need actually
to track a video so I would really get a
little bit complicated and then with
audio files also to check these kind of
stories The Guardian has teamed up with
some 20 other media outlets they formed
a collective called cross-check Nigeria
to support each other in the research
process a story only goes online when
four of the different media
organizations have looked at it
Dalia Aten is one of the coordinators
around 50 journalists are involved in
the project everywhere in the world even
in the u.s. in the most advanced
technology kali advanced politicians
would always use any means to gain
advantage if it is by weaponizing
information they will do that what you
see the important thing is that they
know that once they do it if they try
mechanisms use of technology that can
also out them and so perhaps that would
reduce the incidence of you know
politicians recognizing information for
advantage or to to damage ie tan says
the number of fake stories has increased
in the run-up to the elections Nigeria
is the most populous country in Africa
and it's divided along ethnic lines
which often leads to conflict according
to Nigerian police they have already
been cases of false reports causing
violence so it's not only newspapers who
are reacting to increasing levels of
fake news also Facebook is acknowledging
the issue how to spots false news in 10
steps this is how the tech giant is
advertising in the traditional newspaper
Rouladen wanzer observes a change in the
news business rather than publishers
competing against each other to be the
first to break the story they are now
working together to separate fact from
fiction in times of falling newspaper
circulation
she says this could be an opportunity
for Nigerian media companies
you